22 dicembre 2013 ore 730 del mattino
Alleghe piste da sci gara fisso mi
preparo per fare un paio di giri di
riscaldamento quindi aggancio gli
scarponi mi sistemo la maschera sugli
occhi impugni i bastoncini e parto
prima curva seconda terza quarta e alla
quinta mi accorgo che lo scarpone
interno sta toccando la neve e quindi
perdo gli appoggi e sento che sto
iniziando a scivolare verso il bordo
destro della pista e l'intento di
rialzarmi Ma inutilmente perché sotto di
me c'è già una ripida scarpata
e mentre sono in aria vedo che sto per
impattare contro un albero e per
salvaguardare i miei sci con un
movimento li sposta dalla traiettoria in
un attimo la mia schiena sbatta
evidentemente contro Questa pianta e lì
mi ritrovo a terra
ogni uomo ha due vite e la seconda
inizia quando ci si rende conto di
averne solo una
Ma cosa è cambiato da quel 22 dicembre
Beh da quel giorno sicuramente qualcosa
è cambiato come potete vedere ma mi
riesce difficile raccontare cosa è
cambiato dentro di me perché io non mi
sono mai sentito diverso
So solo che fin da subito ho accettato
la mia nuova condizione e per me è stato
anche abbastanza facile dato il mio
carattere abbastanza
tranquillo e accondiscendente Mentre per
i miei genitori e fratelli molto più
difficile provate solo ad immaginare di
avere un figlio diciassettenne un
fratello che per una stupida caduta da
un momento all'altro rimarrà in sedia a
rotelle per tutta la vita
Ecco io però con la mia positività
Diciamo che penso di averli per lo meno
rassicurati che non era successo niente
di brutto alla fine
certo ricordo perfettamente che non
potevo andare a giocare a calcetto con
gli amici per esempio Però sono sempre
rimasto lo stesso ragazzo lo stesso
ordine di sempre e andavo in discoteca
andavo al mare con gli amici
andavo alle feste di paese ho fatto la
patente ho avuto la mia prima macchina e
Tutto questo grazie soprattutto ai miei
genitori fratelli e amici che non mi
hanno mai fatto sentire diverso
Ovviamente i mezzi non erano più quelli
di prima
Però io ho sempre pensato che fare il
meglio che si può con quello che sia
fosse la miglior soluzione per superare
gli ostacoli
E infatti subito dopo l'incidente il mio
primo pensiero Era quello di tornare al
più presto sugli sci che lo sporco
sempre amato
Infatti la prima volta che mi sono
seduto su monoshi mi ricordo che ero con
mio papà e mi ha accompagnato sulle
piste di sci di San Vito che il mio
paese e con l'aiuto di un maestro ha
fatto le mie prime le mie prime curve e
da lì ho capito subito che potevo
governare anche da solo questo nuovo
strumento e che poi avrebbe accompagnato
la mia vita il giorno per giorno fino ad
oggi
ma torniamo un po' indietro adesso
facciamo qualche passo indietro
quando ero in ospedale a fare
riabilitazione
nel tempo libero Non avevo un granché da
fare
a parte studiare perché andavo ancora a
scuola e
mi sono messo a guardare un sacco di
film che è un mio hobby una mia passione
Anche quella e ce n'è stato uno in
particolare che mi ha segnato ed è un
film che sicuramente conoscerete tutti e
c'è una sua frase in particolare
che mi ha fatto scattare una scintilla
dentro di me il film si chiama Rocky
Balboa e la frase dice
meglio né tu nessuno può colpire duro
come fa la vita perciò andando avanti
Non è importante come colpisci ma è
importante come sai resistere ai colpi e
come incassi e se finisci il tappeto hai
la forza di rialzarti così sei un
vincente e in questa frase mi ci sono
rivisto molto perché io non me la sono
mai presa non ho mai avuto rancore nei
confronti di quello che mi era successo
Ho sempre solo pensato a quello che
potevo fare invece che è quello che non
potevo fare Perciò tutti i giorni mi
sono allenato e ho lavorato come se
nulla fosse
non mi sono mai fermato ai se non mi è
mai importato E lì mi sono riavvicinato
alle competizioni sportive partendo da
dal dall'atletica leggera in questo caso
nel lancio del peso del giavellotto a
cui ho avuto la fortuna nel 2015 di
partecipare ai Mondiali in Olanda e li
ha Ho vinto anche ai Mondiali Junior
Scusate e gli ho vinto anche una
medaglia d'oro una medaglia d'oro In
entrambe le specialità Ecco però in quei
giorni
non mi nascondo che dentro di me nasceva
ancora più forte di prima la voglia di
tornare a fare gare di sci
poi sempre quell'anno ho conosciuto ho
avuto la grande fortuna di conoscere
Lucrezia che è mia moglie
e con la sua amore con la sua sincerità
mi è sempre stata vicino e ha avuto un
ruolo fondamentale nella mia crescita
professionale e umana e mi ha sempre
spronato a dare il meglio di me e poi vi
auguro di trovare un'anima gemella come
lei perché veramente è incredibile
e
poi tutti tutti i risultati che sono
venuti Grazie appunto a tutte queste
persone che mi sono state vicino
sono vengono da costante voglia di
crescere e di migliorare sempre il mio
percorso lo può anche un po' dimostrare
perché sono partito Dalle prime garette
più semplici per ottenere i punti che mi
servivano per entrare in nazionale
dopo essere entrato in nazionale ho
fatto le mie prime gare di Coppa del
Mondo tra cui anche i mondiali di
Tarvisio nel 2017 dove sono caduto sia
un gigante che che speciale poi nel 2018
le Paralimpiadi in Corea dove ho fatto
un settimo e un Ottavo posto nel 2019
quarto ai Mondiali Il Gigante di canesca
Nel 2020 la mia prima vittoria in coppa
del mondo e nel 2021 ne sono susseguite
altre di vittorie ma nel 2022
che è stata la mia migliore stagione
sono riuscito ad ottenere loro nella
combinata ai mondiali di lilhammer e un
bronzo in super g e subito dopo due mesi
dopo
la medaglia d'argento
nello zaino gigante e bronzo nello
speciale
Ecco non volevo
essere diciamo peccare di superbia non
volevo dirvi queste cose ma ha uno scopo
dirvelo perché le ultime medaglie che ho
ottenuto quando me le hanno messe al
collo ho capito davvero quanto mi piace
questo sport e anche perché lo faccio
ciò che non lo faccio solo per voi solo
per me ve lo faccio anche per voi che mi
tifate e che siete qua a darmi la forza
per per andare avanti andare sempre più
forte e regalarvi emozioni è la mia più
grande motivazione
poi credo di essere rimasto
il normalissimo relè cresciuto a San
Vito che insegue che si è impegnato per
raggiungere i propri traguardi come fate
voi tutti i giorni con passione
Ecco io non sono diverso Anzi siamo
tutti diversi però partiamo dallo stesso
punto e poi sta a noi scegliere come
affrontare il percorso e con quale
atteggiamento
ora mi rivolgo a tutti
cerchiamo di dare a noi ma soprattutto
ai nostri figli o futuri figli perché
questa cosa ci tengo tanto perché a me è
servita tanto cerchiamo di dare a noi la
possibilità di fare sport
perché lo sport ci sarà sempre nel
momento del bisogno e vi salverà la vita
come ha fatto con me
[Applauso]